[Music]
the first trailer for x-men dark phoenix
has been released and
unsurprisingly there's a lot of anger
sadness and foreshadowing packed into
the two-minute clip
and we've watched it a whole bunch of
times to help you uncover all the small
details and hints you might have missed
power flare
x-men fans will notice that the trailer
boasts a shot of familiar x-jet the
blackbird
hurtling through space and looking a bit
out of control in the issues leading up
to the original chris claremont penned
comic arc known as the dark phoenix saga
the x-men plummet to earth in a damaged
ship
piloted by jean grey jean is unable to
shield herself
entirely from solar radiation and the
resulting injury in crash landing led to
the birth of the phoenix
sword of gene and sort of not gene it's
complicated
in an interview with entertainment
weekly writer and director simon kinberg
confirmed that in dark phoenix the x-men
do go to space where they're hit by a
solar flare that sparks an unexpected
change in gene
the trailer seemingly offers a glimpse
of this moment when we see a shot of
what appears to be the solar flare right
on the tail of the x-jet
catching fire we saw sophie turner's
gene first tap into her fiery phoenix
powers at the end of x-men apocalypse in
the dark phoenix trailer we're treated
to several shots of gene aflame one
shows her completely engulfed in a fire
that appears to get drawn into her body
she's sporting an x uniform so it's
possible this shot comes from the scene
when gene is overcome by the solar flare
we are treated to a few
other moments when fire burns and the
irises of jean's blue eyes as she
embraces her newfound powers as in the
final shot of the trailer when flame
veins creep over her face we also saw
famka janssen's gene grappling with her
phoenix powers throughout the last stand
that gene failed to control the cosmic
force will this gene have a better
outcome the title card at the end of the
trailer seems a bit
foreshadowing and shows a vaguely
phoenix-shaped flicker of light behind a
group of clouds
island retreat in the late 2017 it was
confirmed that dark phoenix would take
gene to the island of genocia where
magneto has set up a sort of mutant
refugee home
as in the comics the big screen version
of magneto is more complicated than your
average villain with his struggles
against the x-men often coming down to
opposing ideologies more than a truly
evil moral code
jenosha offers another example of his
efforts to aid
mutant kind genocia is a well-traveled
location for mutants in the source
comics first appearing in 1988 as a
wealthy island nation that achieved its
riches by exploiting the mutants born
there as slaves magneto has taken over
the island before in the 1999 limited
series magneto rex
during which he also converted it into a
haven for mutants
home free kinberg makes his directorial
debut with dark phoenix and based on
what we see in this trailer kinberg
revisits key moments we saw in the last
stand which he also wrote
rumor has it that studio pressure led to
much of a script for that film being
edited down
sidelining gene in the process in dark
phoenix kinberg
appears to bring gene back to her
childhood home as she struggles to
restrain her emerging phoenix powers as
he did in his script for the last stand
you have more power than you can imagine
gene the question is
will you control that power
[Music]
here we see gene confront the x-men in
the street outside a house in a suburban
neighborhood
it's likely this marks a turning point
in the film as the symbolism of gene
destroying the home of her late parents
can't be denied in the context
of a film that centers on her struggle
to retain her identity in the face of
her increasingly unrestrained power
sharp-dressed team during that face-off
with her x-men teammates we're treated
to our first clear long shot of the new
x uniforms and it should be a very
welcome sight for longtime fans of the
comic series the design is nearly
identical to the revamped look drawn by
renowned artist frank quietly for grant
morrison's influential take on the
franchise which was published as the new
x-men series
starting in 2001. this series also dealt
with happenings on the island of genocia
but only time will tell whether the new
x-men influence on dark phoenix
stretches beyond costuming or if this is
simply a nod to the character's
illustrious history on the page
cross-examination throughout the dark
phoenix trailer professor x's handling
of gene and her link to her phoenix
power is questioned by those closest to
him
what did you do i had to keep her stable
i protected her mystique isn't the only
blue mutant who questions professor x's
judgment on the matter
later we see hank mccoy confronting the
professor and telling him that it's all
his fault whatever hank is blaming
charles for it's clearly pretty serious
because a still later shot shows the
professor in a standoff opposite magneto
and several of his mutant team
and who's among them but mccoy and his
beast form what could drive this
intelligent
measured academic to take up with
magneto against his mentor and friend
a close-up of hank pressing his
anguished blue face to mystiques may
hold the answer
in the last stand jean's powers truly
moved beyond her control
following her murder of cyclops and the
professor could her turning point and
dark phoenix come when her power leads
to the death of mystique which
leads a heartbroken beast toward the
dark side as well
mystery blonde a closely guarded secret
of dark phoenix is the identity of
jessica chastain's character
the studio has been tight-lipped with
kinberg revealing only that her
character is way way smarter than we are
what she realizes is she can use jean
grey to manipulate this world to turn it
against itself
fans have theorized the unknown woman to
be a version of mastermind the mutant
who invaded jean's mind to brainwash her
further toward the dark side in the
comics
this was shot down by kinberg who did
concede there are elements of the way
mastermind manipulates gene that
jessica's character does employ
you'll see that jessica's character has
elements of a few different characters
from the comics
fans wondered if one of those characters
could be lalondra the shia
empress who's been entwined in the story
of the dark phoenix throughout several
of marvel's comic continuities
fans have also speculated that she could
be based on emma frost aka the white
queen
a telepath who also appeared in the dark
phoenix saga
of course january jones already
portrayed emma frost and x-men first
class so who knows if that will be the
case
dark duds speaking of mastermind one of
the most campy and visually striking
moments from the dark phoenix saga is
jean grey's black queen identity which
she takes on as a result of mastermind's
mental manipulations
a shot later in the trailer shows jean
wearing a dark leather jacket with a
raised collar
along with a more dramatic hairstyle and
earrings we see her in a similar getup
in her earlier clip speaking to chastain
in the church could this be a modified
black queen ensemble a subtle nod to the
change in outfit from the original
comics